We want to zero in
now on
what's happening in Dark
Mood with Kylie Atwood,
who's live for us
at the State Department,
because Kylie, the mercenary group Wagner
has been spearheading
the Russian effort there.
And their leader, Yevgeny Prigozhin,
reportedly
made an offer to Ukrainian forces
back in January that he would give up
Russian troop positions.
He's denying that now,
but it's still a stunning revelation.
Yeah, quite stunning indeed, Boris.
So this is according to
Washington Post reporting
that's based on
leaked intelligence documents
that had leaked on to Discord,
that social media app for gamers.
And according to these documents,
as you said,
this happened in late January.
You give me
Prigozhin, the head
of that private Russian military group
that is fighting
on behalf of Russia
alongside the Russian military
in Ukraine.
Reached out to commanders in Ukraine
and offered to them
that if they were willing
to withdraw
some Ukrainian troops
from around the area of the moon,
that he would share with them
Russian military positions.
Now, we don't know exactly what positions
he was going to share,
what troop movements on the Russian side.
He is privy to.
But according to two
Ukrainian sources
who talk to The Washington Post
and we're familiar with this incident,
there was no agreement
that was struck because, of course,
they were skeptical of the offer
that Prigozhin was offering them.
They really didn't know
exactly what he could deliver on.
And as you
said,
Prigozhin today is coming out
and telegram denying
this is suggesting that
this could have been leaked
by his enemies.
But critically,
we're also hearing from the Kremlin
and the Kremlin spokesperson
saying that they don't have the authority
to speak to these reports
and also saying, quote,
It looks like another hoax.
But what we're watching for here,
Boris, is any actual response
from the Kremlin.
We know that
Prigozhin and Putin
have quite a close relationship.
But if this offer was actually made
without knowledge of the Kremlin,
that could result in
quite a sticky situation.
And so we'll watch
to see how this plays out.
This obviously happened in late January.
So there's been a lot of time since then
so there's a lot to watch
after this report. Boris?
Yeah.
The rift between Prigozhin
and the Russian Ministry of Defense.
Not a surprise.
This could be another front
in that disagreement.
Juliette would from the State Department.
Thanks so much.
The latest stop on Vladimir Putin's keys
whirlwind tour of Europe was England,
where he met today with Prime
Minister Rishi Sunak at his country.
A state that checkers the UK has promised
an aid package
that includes drones and missiles.
President Zelensky,
however, continues
to push for fighter jets,
and he had this to say
about the timing of his country's
long anticipated counter-offensive.
We really need
some somewhere time, not too much.
We will be ready, you know, in some time.
I want to be very honest with you.
I can't share with you some days.
I just don't want to prepare.
Not not for our friends.
There are no secrets from our friends,
but there are some secrets from the world
from our neighbors.
Meantime, on the battlefield,
Russia is dealing with setbacks.
First, Russia's
defense ministry says the two commanders
were killed in action in the Donetsk
region of eastern Ukraine.
Russia rarely announces such deaths.
This as Ukraine's
deputy defense
minister says
Ukrainian forces have captured
more than ten Russian positions
near backward.
Months of fierce battles
have left the eastern
Ukrainian city nearly
empty and heavily damaged.
Some, Kylie is in southeastern
Ukraine with the very latest.
So we know that the UK recently
gave Ukraine
several storm shadow long range missiles.
In addition,
to about $7 billion worth of military aid
so far.
Just walk us through
what more Zelensky needs
from the UK at this point
in time
as they prepare
for that counter-offensive
Was ain on his
shopping trip effectively around
Europe in which he was given
fulsome diplomatic support.
But more importantly, is leaving
with the promise
of a trolley full of equipment,
particularly from Germany
and the United Kingdom.
He's been able to secure
from the British, for example,
long range killer drones
longer range
missiles, more anti-aircraft
missiles, more ammunition,
and from Germany, anti-aircraft tanks,
as they call them, their
wide range of armored vehicles and tanks,
all of it
extremely important as Ukraine prepares
for what is being vaunted, much vaunted
summer offensive
so that has been successful.
What he hasn't yet
been successful on,
but there are indications
that he might be
is in terms of securing the donations
or even sale of F-16 fighter aircraft
fighter bombers,
which is clear now
the Ukrainians have settled upon
as their ideal aircraft
to prosecute this war
so far, NATO
and particularly
the United States have bolt at supplying
what effectively is
a strategic weapon in their view,
for fear of retaliation
on a nuclear level, perhaps from Russia.
But the British have now said that
in the summer so imminently,
they will begin training
Ukrainian pilots in Naito Tactics.
Now, they don't have any F-16s to give,
but they are very vocal
in their support of the idea
that Zelensky
and the Ukrainians
should get those F-16s and they will be
well would be
very, very useful indeed,
since they're pretty much superior
to anything
that the Russians can put into the air,
especially if you combine them
with that heavy NATO's firepower
the very sophisticated firepower
such as Storm Shadow, the British
and frankly, a French
cruise missile
that is now in the Ukrainian army
and being put to use
and that ultimately is what the
campaign will be all about.
It will really hang
from the Ukrainian perspective
on whether or not
they can get behind
the Russian front lines
and break
the back of the logistic structures.
If they can do that,
they're hoping to actually collapse
the whole Russian war effort here
in pretty short order.
That is their hope.
There is no guarantee of that at all.
Of course, the Russians
know it's coming and been digging in.
They may have abandoned
or may even not have,
according to Ukraine,
intelligence, the capability now
to launch offensive operations
of any great significance.
But that doesn't mean
they can't defend the territory
that they're already inside
As you mentioned,
though, the
F-16s would be a game changer for
the Ukraine is in combination
with what they already
have some kind of life force that.
Thank you so much.